- Welcome back y'all.
Individually,
our next guests are
awesome in their own right,
but together they are a true powerhouse
in the worlds of food and entertainment.
They are the force behind the RPM brand,
including several top Chicago restaurants,
and they just opened a new RPM Italian
in Las Vegas yesterday.
Let's welcome Bill and Giuliana Rancic,
along with their executive
chef from RPM Italian,
Chef Eddie Ishaq.
(audience applauding)
So, congrats on the new
restaurant in Vegas.
I almost like dumped that,
that would've been a good start.
Congrats though, on the new restaurant.
That's awesome.
- Thank you.
- Thank you. It's our ninth RPM.
- My God.
- We had them in DC,
we have Vegas that just opened,
and we're opening in West Palm Beach.
So we're really excited.
- People like it.
- Yeah.
- And of course Chicago.
- Well, Chicago is the original-
- Of course.
- Which we opened our
first one up 10 years ago.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- So when we opened the first
one, we thought we were crazy.
And then, who would've thought,
it turned out to be this really fantastic.
- I love that it's like truly
a passion and it worked out.
- It did.
- Yes.
- That's awesome. That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- So what are we making today?
It looks delicious.
- So today we are making Mama
DePandi's Bucatini Pomodoro.
So this is a recipe that
my mom created years ago.
So I was born in Naples, Italy,
and I grew up eating this dish.
My mom worked with chefs and,
you know, our whole team-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Over 30 tries to get this exact dish.
- Oh, I like, she was picky.
- Yeah.
- She was was like, "Not yet."
- Kelly, you would love my mom.
- I love it.
- You would love Mama DePandi.
So, yeah.
So it's our best selling
dish every single night.
In 10 years, nothing else has ever beat it
on any single night.
- Like your mom.
- I know, right? Mama DePandi, yes.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my God.
- So it's delicious.
- Okay. Well Chef Eddie, you're
gonna walk us through it,
right?
- Let's do it.
- You're gonna get us
started? Okay, how do we-
- Beautiful Mama DePandi's Bucatini.
- [Kelly] Okay. What do we do? Yeah.
- So we have the tomatoes
that we strained earlier.
We are gonna keep the sauce to the side.
Kelly and Giuliana,
if you guys wanna add
that sauce to the pan-
- Okay.
- In the pan, we have some diced tomatoes
that we sauteed a little bit,
just to get the nice, the
natural flavors out of the onion.
(Kelly gasping)
Smell that?
- That smells so good
- Smells great.
- The tomatoes-
- It just hit me.
(Bill and Giuliana laughing)
- Very nice tomatoes.
- I might be hungry.
- Super ripe.
- Okay. So what's next?
- So then we're gonna add
a little bit of garlic.
- Love. Can we add all of
it or no, not all of it?
- [Eddie] Yeah. Are you a garlic fan?
Sure, go for it.
- I love it.
No. How much are you adding?
- We're adding a lot.
- No, pour the whole thing.
- Oh, okay, okay. I love garlic.
- Bill's going for it.
- Garlic's good for you.
- It is.
- Go big or go home.
- That's what I say.
- [Eddie] Exactly.
(Giuliana chuckling)
- [Kelly] And then, so what do we do now?
- So we're gonna stir that
for about 15, 20 minutes.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then Bill and I-
- Mm-hmm.
- Are gonna ma build the
Mama DePandi's pasta.
The pomodoro, which we have right here.
- The pomodoro first, sorry.
- Oh wait, what happened?
- Jump on the gun in it. Okay
we'll put little pomodoro in.
- I thought it took you-
- Here we go.
- So it's about a half a cup.
- Got it.
You know, and the great thing about this
is you can make it at
home, which is fantastic.
It's-
- So easy.
- You know, you've got
five ingredients here.
- And kids like this option.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- Yeah.
- We have a nine year old at home.
Our son, Duke. He eats
this almost every night.
He loves it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So then we're gonna add our bucatini.
Bucatini is great for this dish.
It adds a nice thick noodle bite,
and it has like a hole in
the middle of the noodle
so that all the sauces
just go right in there. So.
- Bucatinis are great.
If you've never tried bucatini
at home, you can get it.
- I have never.
- It's so great.
- Oh my gosh, Kelly.
- As we all know our
linguinis, our fettuccinis,
our spaghettis-
- Yeah.
- But bucatini is that like thick noodle.
Once you try it, you wanna get this home
and start making it for your family.
- Look at you, you're like me.
- You are, I'm like aah.
- Wait (chuckles).
- And in all the RPMs,
we make our noodles from
scratch every morning.
- [Kelly] Really?
- So, it's all fresh
pasta, made every morning.
They come in at six in the morning-
- That's why you got nine restaurants.
- [Bill] They roll out the
pot. Yeah, it's really-
- [Kelly] Ah, like people be
coming for that freshness.
- [Bill] This is really authentic stuff.
- [Kelly] Okay, well let's
TV magic after you do that.
- [Bill] Right.
- 'Cause look, I'm smelling it too much
and I wanna taste it. So.
- Yep, me too. Let's get in with you.
- Okay. So we have, it's TV magic.
So we have a finished
plate, like right here.
- [Bill] Hmm-mm.
- Wow, look at that.
- And along with,
wait it says along with meatballs
and I missed the meatballs.
- So we have the prime
meatballs right here
which I don't know.
- Oh, there they are.
- They're sitting out.
- Oh, I was like, I didn't get a meatball.
What the hell?
(audience laughing)
I was like.
- Meatballs are life changing.
- Yeah.
- Made from-
- Well fine.
- A hundred percent
prime beef, here we go.
- Fine.
- These are one of our most popular herbs.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
Get it there.
- I'm like, I wanna try a meatball.
Wait, so explain what's
special about the meatball?
- Well, the meatballs come
from the stockyards in Chicago.
It's a hundred percent prime beef.
Hmm, we are so lucky, we
have such a great team.
They come up with great
recipes, like Chef Eddie.
We have over a thousand
members of the RPM family now.
And they got us through the pandemic.
We have great people.
We had to adapt. We had to adjust.
We came up with creative
solutions to get through it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we're so thankful
that we're through it now.
And people are coming out and working.
- It's interesting though,
with the innovation that
people had to kind of apply,
and now people are still
using some of those
'cause they're like,
"Hey, we didn't know we
could do this before,"
but now people are kind of into it.
- That's right. Yeah.
- It's kind of cool how that worked out.
Half glass full.
- Yeah. That's right. Half glass full.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Absolutely.
- But we're all the way full.
- Or all the way full.
Cheers.
- There we go.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
There's a segue for you.
- Oh go for a wine. There we go.
- Yeah, I was like thank you
guys. I love Italian food.
- Yes. No it's great.
- Okay. So wait, while we are
tasting this beautiful wine,
tell us about the salad.
'Cause what's the salad
situation right there.
- [Bill] What? Here we go.
- Bill and I have the
biggest sweet tooth ever.
We love our pasta, but
we also love our dessert.
So Bill, got a dessert named after him
called Bill's Budino.
- Hmm.
- And I got a salad named after me.
(audience laughing)
Mama doesn't eat salads. Okay.
- Oh my God. I'll eat a salad
if it's good. That's good.
- But I was gonna say, this
is a really good salad.
- Wow.
- So this is really popular too.
It's got beautiful, fresh ingredients,
that mozzarella, tomato, olives.
It's a wonderful salad.
So, I finally started eating salad
once I got a salad named after
me, but that was what I got.
And then our son, Duke-
- Our son Duke has a bone
in filet called "The Duke."
(Giuliana laughing)
I mean he got-
- That's a great name.
- Yeah.
- He got the best one.
- He got like the highest
price thing on the video today.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Exactly.
- He wants 10% of everything.
- He's like I want that one. Yeah.
He knows what he is doing.
- He's a real businessman.
- Job well done, y'all.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Bill,
Giuliana, and Chef Eddie.
So remember, if you're in Vegas
to check out the new RPM Italian.